I was your flight attendant 4 years ago
and here I'm crying on your show now and
we sat in my galy and you cried and
cried cuz you going through so much you
remember what I was going through yes
time I do you were just balling and I
just was holding
[Applause]
you um yeah that was a really really
hard year thank you it was actually the
year um I stopped drinking you know when
you stop drinking it's not like all your
problems go away there was the reason we
met that day and thank you for letting
me be so honest and transparent with you
then and thank you for being that with
me now I don't think we're going to get
anywhere unless we're honest with
ourselves and each other so I love you
and I'm so glad that we're here today
talking about
this